et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés anne
nivat grand reporter de guerre
indépendante bonjour anne bonjour et
bruno daroux de la rédaction de france
24 bonjour bruno graffeurs l'ukraine a
besoin d'une victoire sur la russie sur
le champ de bataille avant toute
négociation de paix la déclaration et de
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien qui dans un entretien qu'il a
accordé au 'financial times' précise les
contours de ce qui pourrait être pour
lui une sérieuse victoire provisoire le
retour à la situation d'avant l'invasion
russe le 24 février et donc le préalable
selon lui à toute discussion avec
vladimir poutine
concrètement ça veut dire que le créneau
horaire conquis par les armes l'ensemble
de son territoire à l'exception de la
crimée de certaines zones du don base
dans les oblasts de loin disque et de
n'y être jusqu'à la ligne de front en
fait en vigueur depuis 2014 ça vous
semble réaliste on y va en tout cas ce
que je constate c'est que le nîmois
zelensky parle parle beaucoup donc
évidemment il se contredit et quand il
parle de victoire provisoire c'est un
peu complexe à comprendre sa victoire
provisoire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
donc qu'est-ce que quand il dit il faut
revenir au statu quo ante et c'est à
dire ce qui était juste avant le 24
février 2022 ça que ça veut quand même
dire que la crimée est annexée par les
russes et qu'il ya les positions dans le
dos de base telle qu'elle s'était de
2014 jusqu'à 2022 mais est ce que ça
veut dire que il compte les reprendre
les reprendre quand mais bon ce qui est
clair c'est hélas il a raison c'est que
rien ne bougera il n'y aura pas de
négociation tant qu'il n'y aura pas d'un
côté ou de l'autre une victoire
militaire sur le terrain
pour l'instant nous ne pouvons pas
avancer de façon puissante sans subir de
lourdes perdre là ce que précise dans ce
trou dans cet entretien zelensky c'est
pour ça qu'il lui faut des armes bruno
daroux oui bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'il
lui faut désormais c'est pour ça qu'ils
n'arrêtent pas d'en demander certaines
qui arrivent mais par exemple la danse
qui se passe dans le donbass le le
rapport à une forme et l'artillerie 1
est en faveur de la russie dans un ordre
de grandeur de 1 à 10 d'ailleurs que la
russie est capable d'aligner 2500 aux
armes et l'ukraine 250 voilà donc c'est
ça un peu le le rapport de grandeur dont
vous voyez que c'est pour ça que c'est
très équilibré j'y repense c'est le
préalable à toute négociation c'est pour
ça qu'ils n'arrêtent pas de dire veut
neymar mais même si après il ya le moral
et la motivation et le fait que les
ukrainiens défendre leur territoire mène
une guerre pour l'indépendance de leur
pays donc c'est très compliqué aussi
pour les russes qui progresse vraiment
maître par m et que c'est un c'est un
combat qui est lent qui est long qui est
très dur pour l'est pour les deux
parties c'est quasiment du maître par m
mais effectivement il dit si on veut
renverser et arriver à la situation
qu'il décrit qui paraît quand même assez
peu réaliste dans un avenir à court
terme quand même un récupérer ce qu'ils
avaient d'ailleurs andreu 14 alors
peut-être qu'ils parlent de victoire
provisions parce qu'ils ont suivi il
veut aussi récupérer la crimée et les et
le goudron basket qui était déjà aux
mains des pro ils n'ont peut-être mais
ça c'est encore plus moins réaliste à
l'aller en tout cas voilà voilà voilà ce
qui pourquoi il demande en permanence
ces armes est encore plus d'armes donc
ce sont toutes les zones assurer
quasiment qu'il faudrait reprendre alors
ses missions de certains certaines zones
du dombasle et
bleu c'est la honda marioupol qui est
prise par les russes
oui enfin c'est là la cette carte montre
bien que tout est entremêlé finalement
tout est entremêlé mais dans une
certaine zone du pays c'est-à-dire l'est
et le sud c'est ça qui compte
aujourd'hui mais d'ailleurs quand même
les ruches conquis l'équivalent de 120
mille kilomètres s à peu près la taille
du portugal pour donner une île depuis
le 20 février
tout cet espace là loin de 20% du
territoire ukrainien oui mais alors le
deuxième pour le reconquérir leur
deuxième offensive celle qui est celle
dans le dos de bases puisqu'ils ne sont
plus à kiev avance quand même très
lentement alors justement le reconnaître
aussi et depuis plusieurs jours ont des
informations confuses à propos de daniel
sévir o2s la ville donc près de louhans
ce que se disputent âprement russes et
ukrainiens la ligne de front et en
perpétuelle évolution dimanche kiev
indiqué avoir repris la moitié de la
ville aujourd'hui moscou assure
contrôler toutes les zones
résidentielles et poursuivre la conquête
de la partie industrielle de la ville où
des civils d'ailleurs ils seraient 800
se serait réfugié actuellement dans une
usine chimique cédér donniez de gamme
va-t-elle connaître le même sort que
marioupol conquise le moins dernier on
s'en souvient notamment avec l'usinage
opstal voilà en y allant même à logis on
est tenté de faire des comparaisons ce
qui est sûr en tout cas c'est que se
donne basse porte bien son nom c'est la
région industrielle de l'est de
l'ukraine donc il y a des grands
conglomérats industriels gigantesque on
a vu ces silhouettes dedans marioupol de
la sauce talent et on a une même
structure de ce type là qui n'est pas
une aciérie mais qui est un autre type
d'entreprise j'ai mis une usine chimique
qui appartient d'ailleurs à un oligarque
ukrainien
et dont la volée ça et mais ce qui est
important c'est de se rendre compte de
la confusion qui règne justement dans
ces vers daniel sévère lyonnais sait à
peu près cent mille habitants en temps
normal aujourd'hui il en resterait plus
que douze à quinze mille qui est
toujours le taux à peu près de ce qui
reste en première ligne de front puisque
vous avez toujours des gens qui ne
partent pas jusqu'au dernier jour elle
était prise sur les trois côtés par
l'armée russe dont qu'il restait encore
un côté qu'est le côté où se sont massés
les troupes de défense ukrainienne mais
aujourd'hui le grand dilemme pour les
hits chance oui parce que licite chaîne
c'est une ville qui en face séparés par
la rivière de 2,6 vers daniel donc les
ukrainiens son côté les six chaînes
c'est fait mais c'est une porte de
sortie donc ils ne peuvent pas pour le
moment les russes n'arrivent pas à
boucler la boucle mais le grand dilemme
de l'armée ukrainienne c'est de savoir
jusqu'où se sacrifier justement c'est à
dire est-ce que hors réitéré ce qu'ils
ont fait à marioupol c'est-à-dire subir
donc laisser les soldats sur place sur
place jusqu'à subir un siège ou alors
les retirer pour ne pas les faire
souffrir ne pas les tuer et finalement
mais au prix de quoi au prix d'avoir
beaucoup plus de mal par la suite à
reprendre la ville en question donc ça
c'est le grand dilemme que se compose le
chef d'état-major aujourd'hui
apparemment qui peut-être un des autres
objectifs de l'armée ukrainienne c'est
d'épuiser l'armée russe alors quitte
peut-être à perdre severodonetsk un
moment ou un autre mais épuisés l'armée
russe en effectif en munitions en morale
en motivation pour qu'après ça au moins
les russes n'ai pas envie d'aller
d'aller plus à l'ouest mais oui parce
que le conseiller présidentiel ukrainien
alexei oreskovic affirme l'armée russe
pour ensuite débuter le siège de ce lot
viance d'ici une semaine c'est ça le
sait il ya quand même il ya quelques
dizaines de kilomètres un autre
severodonetsk esso vincent y sont pas
encore parce que j'étais à ce lot via un
slot vient ses créateurs c'est le coeur
le coeur du donbass
winnie n'y sont pas encore mais ça
bouclerait la boucle et là effectivement
il aurait la totalité de la région auto
proclamée de lougansk ils pointent
d'ailleurs pour ce fait que le retard de
livraison d'armes lourdes occidental
pour des il faut se hâter on voit là
encore assez c'est
le monde dans le faut-il armes et les
ukrainiens entre alors il ya eu des
déclarations aujourd'hui apparemment les
espagnols en face le quotidien el país
qui rapporte ça les espagnols seraient
prêts à livrer des chars leopard 2 qui
sont des des chars allemands qui sont
stockés depuis depuis une dizaine
d'années en espagne et les espagnols les
autorités n'ont pas ni démenti ni
confirmé ni infirmé mais évidemment
alors là si les occidentaux se mettent à
livrer des chars là on entre dans une
autre dimension et là la russie pourrait
considérer que là il ya de la vraie kobe
différence pour quelle autre et les
conséquences on n'en sait rien
visiblement les américains estiment que
tout ce que dit vladimir poutine sur les
menaces extrêmement grave le recours
même peut-être armes nucléaires tout ça
c'est un peu du bluff en fait est que ne
soient ils ne pourraient pas faire
grand-chose tout simplement parce que
toutes les forces qui la mise en ukraine
sont déjà un peu à bout de souffle alors
il vous dira qu'il ne veut pas recourir
à la conscription non plus alors à la
mobilisation générale alors on va y
venir justement puisque être chaud
beaucoup de réactions à la phrase
prononcée par emmanuel macron dans la
presse régionale ce week-end on va le
voir il ne faut pas humilier la russie
pour que le jour où les combats
cesseront nous puissions bâtir un chemin
de sortie par les voies diplomatiques
voilà on va voir à cette phrase
s'afficher dans un instant ce qui lui a
d'ailleurs valu une réplique immédiate
du chef de la diplomatie ukrainienne 1/2
trop coulé bas les appelle à éviter
d'humilier la russie ne peuvent qu
humilier la france nous ferons tous
mieux de nous que nous ferions tous
mieux de nous concentrer sur la façon de
remettre la russie a sa place après lui
dire d'autres ont réagi comme par
exemple la chef chez colas leader des
feymen pour qui la phrase d'emmanuel
macron invite vladimir poutine tout
simplement à continuer la guerre il a
raison on y va de ne pas fermer la porte
à la négociation manuel macron bien est
ce que comme beaucoup le disent lanières
poutine ne comprend que le rapport de
force une fois de plus moi je n'ai pas à
dire si macron a raison ou pas entre en
revanche ce que je peux dire c'est que
leur usage du mot humiliation est très
important
et je pense que là emmanuel macron
a dit quelque chose qui a été mal
compris ses terres il ne faut pas
humilier la russie ça a été compris par
les ukrainiens ils ont pris très mal a
raison parce que c'est eux qui se
sentent humiliés bien sûr qu'ils sont
humiliés puisque ce sont eux qui sont
attaquées ce sont eux qui sont envahis
et donc ils ne peuvent pas comprendre
qu'un leader européen que le président
de la france pense à l'humiliation de
celui qui a attaqué mais dans cette
phrase là emmanuel macron en bon
diplomate qu'il est chef de la
diplomatie française pense lui à
continue ce qu'il a toujours fait ce
qu'il a toujours dit à propos de la
russie c'est à dire laisser la porte
ouverte bien sûr je crois que c'est la
seule chose qu'ils voulaient dire ce qui
revient à prendre lanières poutine pour
un acteur rationnel alors vous aurez
tournée ouais mais vous aurez noté que
dans la forêt noter que dans sa phase il
ne dit pas il ne faut pas humilier
l'avenir poutine oui il ne cite pas
vladimir poutine ce qui veut dire que
quand il il faut pas oublier la russie
c'est le peuple russe l'état russe parce
que un jour oui c'est avec les autorités
russes qu'il faudra quand même négocié à
une sortie de crise un règlement
politique
voilà même si la russie est affaibli ou
au contraire si les combats s'arrêtent
enfin il y aura un moment où il faudra
employer les justes comme il dit les les
voies diplomatiques pour trouver un
chemin de sortie mine mais qui ne cite
pas vladimir poutine ce qui veut peut
être dire qu' il veut dire ce que ce
soit poutine ou pas finalement il faudra
parler russe alors ce qui énerve quand
même certains alors les ukrainiens mais
aussi certains pays de l'est c'est que
ils le prennent presque comme s'il
disait il faut pas eu un millier de
l'avenir poutine et ça évidemment il
trouve ça insupportable mais
effectivement emmanuel macron reste dans
l'ambiguïté parce que lui-même et
personne ne le sait ne sais pas si
vladimir poutine sera encore au pouvoir
dans avec ces rumeurs aussi jean son
état de santé et sur les crispations
sein de deux de l'appareil d'état rei
d'état etc mais enfin bon on n'est pas
on attend deux salles éculés
des choses je moi je ne pense pas que
même s'il y avait un changement de
pouvoir à moscou aujourd'hui il y aurait
une changement radical de politique
de la russie de mettre la main sur
l'ukraine
je pense qu'on est au coeur
d'une espèce de dislocation de divisions
de notre europe et qu'on aura du mal à
s'en remettre on le voit bien justement
avec ses déclarations d' emmanuel macron
qui sont mal perçues mal comprise
et une partie de l'union européenne tire
pour aller d'un côté à côté très pro
américain je rappelle quand même que les
américains n'ont pas du tout la même
situation géographie bien sûr que la
nôtre il ne donne subissent pas cette
guerre de la même façon alors que est
donc finalement nous nous ne réglons
pour le moment rien et je crois que
s'ouvre la dîme un pardon emmanuel
macron s'en rend compte il se rend
compte que il faut laisser faire les
choses militairement volleyeurs élèves
qui le dit aussi puisqu'on vient de
parler de la nécessité de cette victoire
militaire mais qu'en même temps à g à
cause de cette dislocation
diplomatico économique et ses politiques
on n'est pas au bout de nos peines
malheureusement et sa vladimir poutine
le sait aussi bien sûr puisqu'il ne sait
rien mieux faire que de diviser
d'affaiblir les européens que nous
sommes et mange pas que je veux vraiment
que macro il veut effectivement il et
c'est difficile faire exister l'europe
d'un point de vue diplomatique dans le
surtout qu'il est président voilà dans
la recherche d'un doublement de crise
mais même au delà bien sûr qu'à la fin
je la mets et mai alors que et puis par
ailleurs la france comme l'allemagne
sont un peu les grandes puissances
diplomatique de l'union européenne donc
l'accord y sera aussi avec paris avec
berlin alors que les pays de l'est eux
sont d'abord ce centre alors provenir la
géographie mais la c c'est à l'intérieur
même de l'europe ils se sentent beaucoup
plus menacée d'une part et puis ils ont
connu le régent dire à l'histoire ils
ont connu le régime soviétique que nous
n'avons pas connu donc eux ils ont
vraiment très peur et quand on a très
peur on se dit oh la la
ils agressent l'ukraine il faut en gros
il faut le détruire parce que sinon oui
tout ou tard ça va nous tomber dessus
donc en fait c'est pour ça que cette
division à la mais il s'arrête à l'union
ghanéenne mise à part nous devons parler
avec eux aussi nous entendre avec eux et
c'est un des paradoxes de cette 25e dans
un processeur à sortir non mais dans un
premier temps ça ça a permis comme une
consolidation de l'union européenne et
la soude et le roi mois sous de la vigne
avec citation apparente solari ciel
voilé mais il attend ils allaient
s'attendait pas à ce que ça marche voilà
rien en tout cas les et c'est facile de
le dire maintenant qu'on s'attendait pas
devant justement l'ampleur de cette
invasion il était quand même assez
normal qu'on réagisse de façon unie oui
mais il ya eu quand même même je pense
que la liberté ne s'attendait pas
c'était cette réaction aussi une ça ne
sert à rien de savoir à quoi s'attendait
venir ou non il y ait eu quoi et la
fonction à une question arriver oui et
qui sert à rien oui c'est quand même
pris des sanctions non mais d'accord
mais qui s'attendent ou pas c'est à dire
réduire petit pour moi justement n'est
pas fou c'est à dire il n'a pas fait ce
qu'il a fait en se disant tiens il va y
avoir six trains de sanctions qui vont
arriver dans la figure et je vais pas
m'en sortir donc s'il l'a fait c'est
qu'il est convaincu à sa façon avec ses
valeurs les valeurs qu'il défend et qui
sont défendues par beaucoup de monde
dans son pays qu'il a raison et c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui après plus de 100
jours nous en sommes encore là où nous
en sommes pas de victoire claire sur le
terrain et surtout une dislocation des
institutions européennes malgré une
apparence union de location successifs 1
quand même yahya yahya les environs qui
devrait aboutir qui vont qui vont
beaucoup qui vont beaucoup faire
débattre à l'été à l'automne et à
l'hiver parce que justement cette guerre
n'est pas terminée
reste un mot sur la question des armes
toujours toujours elle est la porte et
notamment des armes il ya eu
effectivement ses lance-roquettes
multiples livres et non seulement par
les états unis mais aussi depuis par
l'allemagne et par le royaume uni
faut-il donner les moyens à l'ukraine 2
potentiellement pouvoir frapper le
territoire us même si joe biden
évidemment s'en est défendu amis des
garde-fous verbaux sur ses livraisons
avec le risque là aussi d'une réaction
de la russie je crois pour le moment
personne ne dit qu'il faut aller frapper
le territoire us 1 j'ai entendu aucun
responsable ou alors c'est en personne
et il faut le faire mais en revanche
quelles garanties at on que les
ukrainiens ne le ferons pas seuls ils
ont déjà leur à fait désolé de l'air
déjà ils ont déjà frappé le côté la
frontière belgorod c'est à 40 kilomètres
à l'intérieur des ordinateurs les unités
spéciales bon évidemment et ça c'est sûr
qu'ils le font mais ça c'est la guerre
c'est c'est absolument alors maintenant
on prend un risque inconsidéré mais en
tout cas c'est notre il faut prendre de
la distance aval c'est notre façon à
nous occidentaux de mener cette guerre
ces décisions sont prises par nos
dirigeants en tout état de cause ils
connaissent la situation ils choisissent
d'armes et
l'erythrée la réaction des russes
éventuellement mais clairement il ya un
risque effectivement il ya un risque
absolument il ya un risque absolument
absolument mais mais mais nous nous
choisissons en connaissance de cause ou
alors on va dire que nos leaders
également son fou ne savent pas ce
qu'ils font moi je crois que chacun
essaie de tirer son épingle du jeu mais
tout le monde et en même temps
extrêmement démunies complexe d'hôtels
que c'est un effort voilà c'est vraiment
la spéculation pour dire à la lumière
petit jeu avec les armes nous ont fourni
à l'ukraine voilà ça pourrait toucher le
territoire us donc arrête toi là la
réponse on arrête les combats ont
négocié et on essaie de construire
quelque chose merci bruno daroux merci
également à nivat c'était on va plus
loin rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans quatre minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans paris diact